hello everyone my name is dr. Miller and
the SCP were going to be studying today
is scp-1269 object class Euclid special
containment procedures the property
where scp-1269 is located is to remain
under the custody of the foundation no
females 23 years of age or over are to
enter the property except for testing
purposes one male researcher is to
reside within the property under the
guise of the current resident and is to
monitor the behavior of scp-1269
description scp-1269 is a black aluminum
curbside mailbox possessing a red flag
and a white plastic post scp-1269 stands
1.3 meters tall with a mailbox measuring
49 point 5 centimeters by 15 point 2 by
17 point seven centimeters consistent
with the t2 mailbox size in the United
States the numbers printed on the right
side it lacks any manufacturer's marks
and has minor dents and abrasions
suggesting that the object has been
present on the same property for some
time due to the nature of scp-1269 s
effect the object is permanently located
in Massachusetts in front of house
number Avenue scp-1269 s anomalous
properties will manifest only when a
single female 23 years or older
hereafter referred to as the occupant
resides within the same property as
scp-1269 approximately two weeks after
the occupant moves in scp-1269 will
start to manifest unaddressed letters
every four days the contents of the
letter are romantic in nature and are
targeted towards the occupant of the
house surveillance within scp-1269 has
shown the letters manifest approximately
three seconds after the occupants mail
has been delivered
exactly three weeks after the appearance
of the first letter scp-1269 secondary
anomalous properties will manifest
letters will begin appear in daily with
contents becoming increasingly more
obsessive and erratic until the point
that the letters regress into single
sentences in some occasions multiple
letters will appear within scp-1269
additionally when not under direct
supervision of the occupant scp-1269
will teleport to a location near the
occupant and face them this location
will be partially obstructed such as
behind windows cracked doors and shower
curtains under special circumstances
such as during sleep or when obscured by
darkness scp-1269 will teleport near the
occupant without obstruction whether or
not the occupant relocates scp-1269 the
object will continue to teleport between
a range of one to five times every 12
hours scp-1269 will not follow the
occupant off the property and all
anomalous properties will cease
manifesting after the occupant is either
moved or expired attempts to remove
scp-1269 from its location have so far
been unsuccessful as CP 1269 will
teleport to its original curbside
location after one hour of relocation if
attempts are made to replace scp-1269
with a new mailbox the mailbox will be
teleported away with scp-1269 appearing
in its place approximately three hours
after the disappearance of the new
mailbox it will reappear in a dumpster
25 kilometres away behind an abandoned
franchise mailbox is recovered so far
have all been found in varying amounts
of disrepair within garbage bags and
covered and painted on words and phrases
addendum scp-1269 a on July 12 2004 d69
12 for a male was moved onto the
property with a current test occupant D
72 83 after seven weeks had passed
scp-1269 stopped teleporting at this
time three days later he's 69 12 for
disappeared from the property causing
scp-1269 to resume all anomalous
behavior two weeks after the
disappearance d 69 12 4 was found in a
similar location as the other
replacement mailboxes the subject was
found within a large garbage bag with
severe bruising and lacerations and
apparently fatal blow to the head and a
lack of hands and lips see documents
scp-1269 b4 recorded phrasing documents
scp-1269 a transcribed below are several
letters delivered to d 87 1523 who
temporarily resided within the property
of scp-1269 for testing July 21st 1998 I
remember the day the hour the
infinitesimal sliver of a second when I
fell in love with you realized I loved
you and only you the moment my heart
stopped and I lived for you alone
perhaps was the way you carried yourself
on the tired days perhaps it was the way
your eyes Shawn what a transient beauty
crossed your path would you understand
how I longed it to be that butterfly
dancing on the afternoon breeze that
small flower struggling through the
sidewalk cracks that passing Swan like
cloud in the sky how I longed to be
anything that would catch your eye and
move your smile you pass by me each day
never sparing me more than a glance but
for me it's enough to carry me until the
next day as I wait to next catch a
glimpse of you and your unearthly beauty
you're charming laughs and graceful step
I love the way you dance whenever you
walk I love the way you tilt your head
towards the Sun I love everything about
you I love you
August 9th 1998
how could anyone describe one as perfect
as you vision of elegance and loveliness
every action of yours I've observed is
embodied in the fragility and delicacy
of a twirling snowflake and yet you
waltz into eternity with the softest of
motion in perfect rhythm with air and
the world
you are beautiful every step every pause
every breath of yours is a masterwork of
the divine your presence brightens the
world with a light that cannot be
compared you are the flower that nature
cannot hope to match august 15 1998 the
color of your eyes reminds me of the
depth and expanse of the night sky a
vast dazzling macrocosm of soft velvet
and glimmering pinpricks of light august
18th
1998 do you sing in the shower if so
I've heard you such a tenderly beautiful
voice matches its owner August 21st 1998
I think of you and nothing but you as
the day flows by I yearn for a faint
shimmer of your face as everything
darkens tonight
August 24th 1998 the wind was blowing
and I thought it whispered your name
sadly because that is what my heart is
doing please write back
I keep thinking of the way your hair
shines softly in the evening light as if
each strand is a shaft of purest
moonbeams
please write august 26 1998 the trees
drop their leaves and cry with me as i
stand here alone without you please
write kiss hug kiss hug my shadow grows
longer as if reaching towards you please
write as how could kiss hug kiss hug I
miss the light in your eyes and the
harmony of your voice please write kiss
hug kiss on kiss hug documents scp-1269
be transcribed below our various phrases
written on mailboxes disposed of by
a-c-p 1269 she's mine she's mine she's
mine she's mine you can have her she's
mine she's mine do you pile of plastic
and wood she is my everything you are
nothing to her it was a fling and I know
what I'm doing her a favor no no no no
no no no you can't have her no no I
won't like you no no no
who cares if your flag is bigger than
mine I know she doesn't care she only
sees the good in people and you are full
of [ __ ] you've hurt
I know she loves me it's okay baby it's
okay I love you too and we'll be
together forever and ever you were
nothing but a tool for her to use but I
am more I am for everything as she is
mine
she used you she used you she used you
and now you're where you belong
see addendum scp-1269 a what is a man
but a pile of street it gets in the way
of my love how could she ever love you
when you're so easily broken she never
even lets you touch her I saw the way
she looked at you with hatred and now
she will love me forever and this
concludes our lecture today just stick
to email it's easier it's faster and you
don't need to talk to a mailbox I don't
know but but I think that about does it
for today thank you all for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to albino Neku GM's
Sabah Andre de shirt
Jax Marek Pablo ice 917 Burlington the
cat all the time gaming Justin day
researcher bull veer Pierce M Hamlin
Curie kuma white crew Nicholas James vu
Jack Bryce and Billy my archive curator
Nick cootie tench the Android slump god
quartz 5 6 3 i'm tree hero thank you all
so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volga thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]